hello and welcome to this video i play
the same guy again
that's funny
what kind of person is that actually is
there something
he's got a reasonable amount of games
so we have a closed sicilian
that how does that work again
this position
knight d4 i think
my knight d5 is a bit surprising
it's not how you usually um play this
yeah i think i just castle
yeah knight f5 knight b5 looks uh
odd
well let's go to f5 it's playing this
very quickly
like he somehow um
knows this or has prepared it
which seems a little bit unlikely
what about pawn takes is that a terrible
idea it's a bit
uncommon
to play it like that because you want
the bishop open
on the other hand i have a really nice
square on d6
for the knight and i have f5 coming
so this is an interesting idea
um
so he's aiming at the e4 square i am
okay 96 i guess or
96 it's probably going to play knight e4
okay c5 is it's just is hanging i have
to
do something about that i think probably
just b6
and then go for f5
yeah f5 next i have to watch out for
knight
g5 e6 then he's not
obliged to take on d6
i mean he might do it but he's he's not
forced to do that
should i play h6 maybe
yeah i think this is quite useful anyway
if f5 is played g5 is also
coming into consideration soon after so
king h7
it's a little bit there's some pressure
here so
on the king side i have to be
circumspect not to allow a tactic okay
so f5 now he will definitely take
the knight has no squares
and now what
the standard thing for me to do is
something like bishop to d7
okay so he covers this reliably
should i go g5 yeah just just
not spend any more time i think this is
right
there's no particular reason why i
should play bishop d7 first and connect
rooks
something that probably has to be done
at some point but
f4 is an immediate threat okay so
f4 there's d4 check
i guess so
just play bishop d7
i will probably have to play
king h8 sometime okay this this i can do
make before more difficult to play
the move f4 in itself is not it's not
devastating for white
you can move the bishop away to d2 and
just
basically stay put
it's maybe double on the f file
g4 i have f4 it's not i think a problem
okay maybe he wants to go to c3
bishop f3 um
rook h7 king g7 rook h8 is my idea
in a tough position so go here
i wonder if he has enough quick play
against
g7 he can pile up on that quite a bit
rookie one
okay i'm now over think
[Music]
yeah i probably have to take at some
point
bishop takes i guess no
if e4 would be nice
takes takes
don't see it working yet
huh i didn't really see this idea i mean
it's super simple but
it could have taken when i had king f6
at the end
bishop e5 i have queen h8 check
oops
should be fairly simple to win this
i have all the pawns on dark squares so
they're not going to fall
yeah and i'm promoting it was a tough
game i
really don't know i mean obviously he
blunted the piece but um
tough to say before right let me
let me have a look here
so he played this in my mind
a little bit surprising move knight d5
it's hey it's it's liked by the engine
interestingly i i
have a hard time to
to believe that it is great
i just think that the bishop should be a
permanent
problem here looking at this this pawn
i mean not like white is losing or
anything i just thought it it's not
really dangerous
okay so castles c3 knight f5
and he took yeah interesting bishop
takes
is maybe the more
conventional take if there's something
like that in a position
in this position here that would at
least keep the
the diagonal open but with the pawn on
c3 this is not
it doesn't feel so relevant so this is
also liked
more by the comp so this
v6 looks fairly normal
now h6 is the best move it seems yeah
or one of the best i mean i would like
to play f5
just like that but i was unsure about
this move
it turns out that f4 is strong okay
no that was not
not within my ability
yeah this is just this is too much
hanging
okay but h6 is not a mistake went king
h7
and knight f5 back that is actually very
true
yeah if i can do that and he cannot run
away with the bishop so
i get this important piece that's
definitely an alternative but it's
pretty much it's not a very human
decision there you have prepared f5 all
the time
so this is normal i guess
g5 okay yeah
f4 f4 still i mean this is
maybe i was just too superficially i was
scared about this
check but i can play here
huh
ah of course sim of course i completely
i did not i didn't get that i can do
this
and now he has to take him there's no
other move and this is also attacked and
the queen is attacked so
and now the bishop is hanging but this
is also hanging twice so
i'm just fantastically better even e4
is possible like here there is this
tactical opportunity
so then f4 was a good move probably i
mean he can play bishop b2
and should play bishop d2 and then we
get something quite similar to the game
probably just in a somewhat better
version yeah the the position in the
game
i have no clue what's going on you just
go ahead a little bit f4
so okay i missed e4 here okay
oh that's indeed a miss e4 f3
this is opening up that bishop all of a
sudden
i mean it's not like i'm winning the
exchange because of bishop c3 but
that becomes a clear option here for
example
with um this move
now also part of the position it could
be interesting tactics like
this this and rook takes here right yeah
rook takes works
this this this is
made somehow right this this this and we
have a mate
funny line so there were some chances
here okay but
it's it's just what it is it's blitz h5
bishop f3
so this seems to be roughly equal
and then we got to this moment when
okay
i played this i was thinking about e4
somewhere around here but i couldn't
quite make it work
so it is just like i should play this
and play for the compensation is what
the engine is claiming here
but this is not so easy to do like e5
i do understand i have this and the
attack on the h file is very strong
but he has rook h1 i'm just trading yeah
okay but that would be a very logical
way to play like e4
get this bishop yeah out
and play actively but okay i couldn't do
it rookie one i played king f7
he can take on e5 but this is not so
good i think
i thought i'd take everything and play
king f6
yes that's indeed working and then if
the rook
returns he has no square here returns i
can probably just take g4
and those two oops those two connected
pawns should be pretty strong at least i
was sure i'm not worse and the computer
confirms that in fact black is much
better
so rook h1 was played and that loses
ah ah e4 oh that's
actually simple it's actually simple
yeah because this is a tempo so bishop
here i take this
ha okay
yeah no i didn't see it i okay i had
seven seconds but still it's not such a
difficult tactic
this one and then yeah he stumbled into
into this and now i'm winning
easily i mean seven seconds um with an
increment is um
is not a problem really um you don't
lose on time but
still if you have seven seconds you have
to move quickly and sometimes even
simple tactics are overlooked
okay guys thanks for watching